[Music]
um yeah I think we can all relate to the
uh domain of healthcare um and that's
also what makes this so nice to work on
uh on this product actually everyone you
talk to has at least someone they know
that had an an operational surgery or
had a surgery themselves um and actually
unfortunately in some cases uh this can
lead to an infection quite a number of
cases but I'll I'll go in more depth
later
um we found out this morning that we
forgot to update the outline um so I'll
just give you a very short recap um we
have two sections of the talk so the
first section is me talking about the
higher level overview of what we've done
and basically the problem we're trying
to solve with our product and then lens
will take over and he will he knows a
lot more about the machine learning
models behind it so he will go more in
depth on the models and also the
performance of those models
models so um yeah we're also talking
about challenges and as you can see this
is the timeline of Health Plus AI um the
company was founded in 2017 with four
people um I entered the company I think
around
2021 um and we've basically explored uh
AI Solutions in healthcare so we've
looked at all these different sort of
models that we could develop to make an
impact on Healthcare uh it actually the
company arose out of frustration of our
founder he's a he's a doctor uh oh I
didn't do anything yeah um that's
probably AI as well I don't
know he saw that most things in
healthcare they're very reactive so
someone gets sick and then you start
treating while actually you want to be
more on the preventive or the proactive
side uh we're not saying we're
preventive but we try to be in the more
proactive side so we want to help
doctors make decisions that Cor actually
benefit the out uh outcome of the
patient so we started in 2017 explored a
couple of different options um then in
2021 basically zoomed in on infection
prediction and did a proof of concept at
the lights University Medical Center um
we secured some funding to actually grow
the team to about 12 people um we
entered the world of C certification and
I'll talk more about that in the next
slides um and then um we're at the
moment at the point of uh looking at our
second stage audit so all the way in
December which would be the like the
final point for certification after that
it's still three to nine months till we
actually may hit the market so we're
only allowed to do things in the market
once we get certified which is I think a
good
thing um so the problem we see that 17
to 25 uh% of the surgical patients they
get an infection after surgery which is
of course first of all for the patient
itself it's a it's a super bad thing so
uh think about the pain that is is also
combined with the with the infection at
the same time and we're a commercial
company it's also a cost impact on on
Healthcare basically um we uh I I don't
know have the numbers by heart but
there's millions of extra cost because
patients get an infection have to be
readmitted to the hospital and treated
um to the hospital so we're very bad
also at detecting infections early on so
we only real iiz it after a couple of
days that something is wrong with the
patient um at the same time we know that
in healthcare there's plenty of data
there's all these like most hospitals in
Europe they have electronic health
record systems so every little bit of
data is stored from a patient so Vital
Signs uh lab results all these data
points they're actually there but we
only use a very little amount of that
for to actually add
value um we have a short in in health
workers so there's a lot of U of people
working working in healthcare but not
enough to treat all the patients to give
all the patients the uh uh the the
attention that they need and at the same
time expenses of the Healthcare System
they increase steadily over the years so
that's that's another thing oh that's
good well um it can read my mind so what
do we do to solve this we've made a
medical decision support system so what
we do is we look at um uh the data
that's already in the EHR so in the
electronic health record system uh and
then we see if we can predict uh the
risk of an infection uh that uh of a
patient after a surgery so um uh we do
that by just integrating within the
workflow of the uh the clinician so
we're directly integrated in that EHR
system we also offer a uh additional
view so it's not just a prediction but
we offer a Consolidated view on the data
that's present so we try to bring all
the information that the clinician needs
to decide on what to do after an
infection has been diagnosed we bring
that to one single screen in the EHR
system so what does it look like um we
have this infection dashboard which is
their main overview you see on the left
side the infection we predict for the
probability of an infection within seven
days and within 30 days we connect it to
a risk uh score so high medium or low uh
and on the right side you see all the
vital parameters the lab results um the
uh lines for example that a patient has
received um the extra thing we do so for
explainability we also talk about the
predictive factors so we show the
predictive factors that contributed to
that infection uh
prediction some of the challenges um
I've already said it during the coffee
break to some people like getting data
was one of the main obstacles we faced
and of course you can imagine privacy is
uh is pretty string pretty stringent so
it took quite a lot of time to actually
get data to base our development on um
then data is not standardized so we have
all these EHR systems there's a couple
of vendors there's actually one vendor
that's almost do that's dominant in the
Netherlands has the biggest market share
um but still every hospital can do their
own sort of additions to the data
structure and mostly also the content of
the data so they have different coding
schemas Etc um so it's not really
standardized the structure of the
database usually is but the content
definitely not uh and then the C
certification part so uh we're a small
company uh like I said 12 people at the
moment um we can only actually Implement
our product in in the market once it is
a c certified so we have to prove uh in
a very elaborate way that we're safe to
use that's the main goal of that
certification and this is a easily a
two-year
process so going a little bit more uh on
the architecture so uh what does it look
like we have an EHR system uh we have an
ETL process that's still Hospital
specific we extract the data uh we send
it we push it actually into our solution
which is called
Periscope um and then we process the
data we generate the uh the dashboard
out of that uh and finally present it
through the EHR system back to the the
end
users um going a little bit into a
development strategy we have a strategic
partnership with SS um but we've said
also to we work with a lot of data
scientists data engineers we want to
make our development uh flow basically
all in Python so we have an open source
development core and what we do is we we
actually convert that to SS to have our
first version of the product uh and at
the next year so in
2024 we're also planning to do a python
only version of of our product so we
actually formalize the python code that
we already wrote in that development
stage as you can see all sorts of nice
open source um packages that we can
actually use there and then uh louds you
can brief us a bit more on the models
yeah so um can I get a like a a reading
of who you are um who of you are data
scientist and working on developing
models okay and um so the surprise for
me always is that if your model is done
and you're satisfied then you don't have
a product yet right but showed us our
interface so this is this is the model
output this is the number that I've been
working on but this is what our users
will be using so that's a huge
difference but I will tell you how how I
got to this
number and um to get that we used of
course uh supervised machine learning
and to do to use supervised machine
learning you need a label you need a a
ground truth and the first year of our
uh product development was getting that
ground truth narrowed down because you
have these EHR systems in the hospital
and B told you um everything is
registered
observations um uh notes from medical
stuff with the patients but it's all
free text and there's registration
systems like um complication
registrations but it's not complete for
in so what you see here is a pie chart
of um patients after surgery and the the
green circle it's the the amount of
patients for whom uh infection is
registered but the can't see the colors
the red circle it represents all the
patients that have been prescribed
antibiotics after surgery and you only
get prescribed anti
antibiotics if you have an infection of
there's if there's a strong suspection
that you have an infection so we should
consider these patients to also have an
infection and there's also a small part
of patients that actually go back into
surgery after their primary surgery to
get some infection treatment for
instance for wound cleaning
or um well for Orthopedics there are
some more more intensive follow-ups but
that's not get too visual but um so we
have spent a lot of uh time debating or
discussing with different Physicians
from the hospitals with whom we've been
corporating on how do we um pinpoint the
patients that actually do have an
infection and eventually we decided to
take this whole population so if you
have infection registered or if you have
been antibiotics or if you have gone
back to to surgery we we will consider
all these events as a positive label and
all all the other patients so for whom
this does not uh occur that's the
negative population and that brings us
to an incident range of rate of about
10% so that's what we are um working
with so then Bart told you about how the
how diverse um the data is of course
here in the Netherlands we have two
large suppliers for EHR systems it's
chipsoft and it's epic um but with our
MDR certification we will be um able to
to uh Supply uh hospitals in all of
Europe so it's it's a diverse field so
what we've been building is um data
loading part where there's a hospital
specific part that does ETL and
transforms the hospital data into a
uniform set of um tables from which we
can then build a feature Matrix on which
we can train our
models and we've tried to separate
different stages in this ETL process so
first we will um start with um the data
in tables as the hospital supplies it to
us and we will do a structure mapping to
a structure that we know so with a
defined set of columns and a defined
data types per column um and from so
then we have data that we know and we
can work with but then there's a lot of
knowledge that's that we still need to
add for instance there's a condition
registration but it's a lot of really
specific conditions and like thousands
of them repes represents infections and
another 100 represents pregnancies and
we need to be to able to detect that so
currently we have some two Medical
Specialists working with us who go with
if we are lending at the new customer
who will go through all these conditions
and label all the conditions that sign
signal infection and label all the
conditions that signal pregnancies and
that's for conditions but it's also for
observations and for procedures so
that's a lot of manual work but when
we've done when we've done that we have
a set of data that is really concrete
and uh uniform and then we can run our
system and we can easily train our model
and
um uh and then use it in
parascope so then you of course okay
okay so this is and then how do we train
our model um we've used tfold cross
validation and a temporal validation
with an 8020 split where the we've
chosen tempor temporal split to show
that we can actually learn from
historical events to say something about
the future at least the more recent past
in this case of course and then within
this validation set we've also done a
subgroup analysis so that we identify
for the different populations within
thator
validation validation set
that we perform equally well on each
subgroup this way we try to detect bias
or uh prevent bias from
happening and this way also we report
that our model is actually safe for use
for an entire population for a hospital
and for the different groups within that
hospital so yeah yeah we've done this
now with the LM and with rbout in the
Netherlands and we're currently working
on expanding this uh across the border
with uh Hospital from the Bel Belgium
from Belgium and from Denmark so I'm
really excited to see that our approach
for now I'm working on the data from
this hospital and it it it works just as
well so I'm excited to see that our
approach actually works um across the
border and then you're curious to what
we uh managed to get as
results uh so I've cramped them up into
one slide um does everyone know what an
au curve is yeah and what a calibration
curve is okay so for us um as we are uh
showing the percentage of uh infection
chance and we are asking our users to
work with that uh the accuracy and the
Precision they're not that important
because we don't translate it to a zero
or one to a definite infection or
definite non- infection so we are aiming
for to maximize the Au in our um in our
model and this is where we got to um
which I'm very happy to see that the
performance between the train set and
the test set is really equal so that
suggests a pretty good external um
external well external
bability um so these are the curves and
then the calibration curve of course is
important if you want to show the
outcome of our model as a percentage so
this we you see here that our lines are
on the diagonal of the calibration curve
so we can say that if uh our model um
gives a 40 % chance actually 40% of the
patients that get that outcome do
develop an infection after
surgery so with this so I told you
currently we're oh yeah just question
about the bottom row yeah oh yeah yeah
sorry that's a that's so what we were
also wondering is now we are doing this
procedure per hospital but it would be
nice of course to work with a
pre-trained model and um start that in
uh in new hospitals so what we've tested
here is what if we have trained the
model on the LMC data RB data and use it
for the LMC population and the other way
around and you see a significant drop in
performance so right now we don't we
cannot use this approach yet in our
opinion um but you would hope that um
getting more hospitals with whom we can
develop our product we can narrow this
down and then maybe we don't need to uh
calibrate our model at each new side
numers
what
get that's a study that we're so your
question is um how does this compare
actually to not using the product and do
we actually provide an advantage for the
hospital so of course our as B told you
we don't have a c certification yet so
our product is not being used um we are
comparing right now um our product to uh
decision making as it is right now um
but we what we cannot test yet is how
does decision making right now with our
product improve the outcome of patients
or Val
foros
yeah um it will be because of the change
in population and a new each hospital
has their own specialty and then so that
but it's also because um when we think
about data we think about numbers and we
hope that an high temperature predicts
an infection for instance in our case or
something in the blood pressure but very
often I think uh a high dimensional
model uh machine learning model it will
not pick up on the actual temperature
readings but the fact that the physician
actually chose to read a temperature or
to order a lap test so there's I think a
lot of um
Decisions by Healthcare practitioners
that our models learned from and these
decisions differ per hospital that each
Hospital have to has their own protocol
and their own
um uh yeah approach to to
healthcare yeah so as I told you we are
now working on expanding more moreos
more hospitals especially across the
border um but as we see the US
approaching Market there's three points
that we are um working on right now so
maintenance key we're working on uh
building the software to monitor the
performance while the model is being
used and also to monitor the data that's
coming in while the model's being used
and we have are now in contact with uh
the EHR vendors to to also actually make
that seamless integration possible to
make the our The View that we have built
to make that available in the EHR
system um and as I've told you these
mapping the these mapping files so the
mapping from the hospital specific
conditions to the conditions that the
signals that we you need it's a lot of
work so we will be also we also need to
build tooling to uh speed this up to
speed this proc process
up so that's it for
[Applause]
us
yeah what kind of special tricks do you
do I can speak very loud what kind of
special tricks do you do for
explainability towards the the
users so maybe maybe it's not that
special we used the shapley uh Library
um and we picked the top 10 predictors
based on impact and what we've uh
consciously chosen is to not order them
by magnitude of the impact because you
have to prevent this cality correl
cality versus correlation effect where
you have to prevent Healthcare
practitioners from seeing this as the
buttons to on which to uh turn in order
to change the outcome for the
patient thank you um so as a a
commercial company which you are uh how
difficult was it to get access to the
EHR records to do these types of
analysis or under what conditions do you
get access I
can oh well um it was I think one of the
main challenges we faced when starting
the company I wasn't involved at that
stage but I know it took about two years
to get our first data set coming through
also because of gdpr of course that got
introduced about the same time um in
terms of what to do you have to prove
that you can actually deal with this
information in a in a secure way so you
have to well we're not 27,1 certified
yet but we'll get that next year but you
have to show that you have your
information security management system
in place and that you do certain have
certain controls implemented to uh um to
deal with the data in a secure way also
our initial projects have all been
research projects so they're combined
projects with the hospitals uh and this
helps a lot as
well oh yeah uh thanks for the
nice talk um I was wondering what you do
with um monitoring and especially
updating uh especially I I think that
that might also affect your C uh
certification
right so to get a c certification you
have to write an extensive monitoring
plan so um we will monitor the the model
outcome um and detect uh drop in
performance um
but there's no life learning or
something like that so
um it might be so right now so the the
temporal validation that we've used it's
two years so right now we say that the
model is valid for two years and then
you need to update it and then you need
to like redeploy it that's
the
approach again thanks for the talk uh I
wanted to ask did you experience res
assistance in the adoption of U these
smart Solutions in the medical field and
if so was it based on reasonable
resistance or was it uh mainly the habit
of doing the the same way the same thing
in the same
way also I think that's a bit early to
really give a full answer on that
because uh like laen and I we're not
implemented yet so we still have to go
through the challenge of actually having
it implemented with Healthcare
professionals
um but we do see a lot of enthusiasm in
the Forefront so let's say the early
adopters in healthcare about the model
so um actually in this stage we're
already approached by hospitals uh that
want to use our solution which I think
is a is a signal that also it's a hype
so I'm also very aware that this AI hype
especially after J GPT we're really
riding that wave um but at the same time
um you do see like sincere interest from
also Medical Specialists but they I have
to say those early adopter they are a
special kind of medical specialist that
they are prone to being interested in
these kind of Technologies I'm sure
we'll encounter people that put some
resistance and I think that can be
expected it's it's not something that
I'm too worried about uh but it is
something that we have to definitely
take care of and that's also why I mean
the explanatory factors they're
important but also like the whole right
side of that dashboard it shows
information that's already there which
is useful in that whole decision making
so hopefully that also lowers the the
threshold a little
bit also there's the work
pressure also there's the work pressure
in healthcare so a lot of healthcare um
uh professionals they are really looking
for tools to lower the workload to burn
them uh yeah thanks for a nice talk uh I
was wondering how do you guys deal with
like the free unstructured Tech
structure because uh I've seen I guess
like mapping you have like sections like
BMI and then you have like a number but
do you do you guys also use for example
uh you have like history of patient
illness where a doctor writes like a
quick summary of what happened uh how do
you guys yeah deal with that and how do
you guys map that actually it was kind
of yeah that's a very good question um
we don't we only use the structure data
but there is hope there is but yeah but
I would love to to spend some time on
that yeah I think you that was the same
question um so you're now if I
understand correctly the CE
certification is on European level right
are there any other major blockers when
you roll out your products uh to operate
on a European level or once you get that
it's go time you have to also deal with
local regulations of course also in
Europe I mean you have the EU laws but
countries have their own local
regulation um besides the EU I'm sorry
besides the EU we're also looking at the
US of course and there you have the FDA
which also has a an approval kind of
mechanism uh that we'll have to go
through so for Europe we have to oblig
to all of the the local regulations and
that that that could be another
bottleneck or
challenge um what's what's the reasoning
for going first in Europe uh instead of
uh in the US with the FDA what's
the um we're based in Europe so that's I
think that's the main um but there is
it's of course debatable what strategy
uh uh you would choose I know for um an
FDA approval you need also data from the
US to prove that you're safe um and
actually in the US they have a different
kind of business model you have to pay a
lot for that data which is I mean as a
starting company it's it's probably too
much for us um we're we do have a
partnership now with a US Hospital which
basically cut us a good deal on on the
data so we're making steps there as well
shall
I so you said that um the result seems
to be very uh sensitive to the procedure
used in the hospital uh how are you
going to ensure that this product is not
going to change the procedure that is
being done if they see a number and they
see Ah that's because I did the
procedure like this they might change
the
procedure uh and then the model suddenly
doesn't give the result
anymore yeah so for one um we offer our
users the prediction at the point after
surgery the moment after surgery and we
use all the data up until that point so
the data that goes into the model it's
not changed by what the physician sees
and decides to do um but then the
labeling process might but the labeling
process it um it's not only on
the
rad conditions as I've shown you but
also on the given care the antibiotics
and and so there there might be a change
and we will be monitoring for it and if
it if if it it's there we need to act
open it but it might also be quite small
um because if there's an infection it
will be treated and if there's no no
infection um so the danger that I see is
that there's given antibiotics just
because there might be an infection um
which is of course more and more en
discouraged in Europe um but it differs
per country how easy antibiotics is
being prescribed so we'll see if that
happens
I would think to be honest so yeah I I
see your point and um indeed we would
retrain and pick up that signal right
that that would be the the
answer it sounds to me like the data
would improve so I would be I would have
be happy with uh more
measurements
yeah but I think when you get more than
10 questions that means that the talk
was a success so thank you so much
thanks a lot uh S Lawrence and a lot uh
but let's give him an Applause and
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah